est ce qu'un jour on verra l'interview
d'un chien intelligent qui aurait appris
le langage des humains ils vous
raconterez ce qu'il a fait aujourd'hui
comme all ce sens et on pourrait
véritablement comprendre ce qui se trame
dans son cerveau un tel scénario est il
possible le cerveau d'un chien d'un
singe ou d'un humain sont très
similaires
alors qu'est ce qui leur manque pour
nous parler et la science est ce qu'elle
peut faire quelque chose pour leur
donner cette capacité par exemple par
une machine ou une mutation génétique
on va étudier ça et la réponse risque de
vous faire froid dans le dos les animaux
ont-ils les organes pour parler à part
ouf
aimia où on peut pas dire que les
animaux disent des choses intelligible y
en a bien qui essaye mais c'est
clairement de la surinterprétation le
truc c'est qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'animaux qui sont capables d'émettre
des cris humain est il ce même chez nos
plus proches cousins le singe par
exemple parce qu'on a beau avoir 98% à
des ânes en commun les chimpanzés sont
pas connus pour avoir des vocalises très
variés pourtant ils ont tout ce qu'il
faut le nez pour faire résonner le son
la langue pour sculpter les mots et
surtout la larynx avec deux cordes
vocales fonctionnel
il ya quand même quelques différences
alors larynx et plus haut ce qui laisse
moins de temps au sens pour être modulée
mais les bébés humains ou même problème
et ça les empêche pas d'essayer de nous
imiter
des scientifiques ont donc décidé de
faire comme jurassic park scanner le
larynx d'un singe et essayer de
reproduire informatiquement ce que ça
donnerait s'il parlait c'est flippant
mais donc oui contrairement à ce qu'on
pensait avant un singe et anatomiquement
capable de parler et même si son
appareil phonatoire avait été très
différent ça n'aurait pas de temps était
un problème on a des exemples d'animaux
très éloigné de nous capables de
vocalises humaine bien sûr on va parler
du perroquet mais d'abord parlons des
animaux de zoo car à force d'être en
contact avec nous certains essayent de
nous imiter
au point où ça fait froid dans le dos
[Musique]
maintenant l'animal le plus connu pour
ses imitations c'est évidemment le
perroquet c'est bluffant
et bien sachez le les perroquets nos pas
de cordes vocales
il utilise un cyrax qui est située
beaucoup plus bas juste au dessus des
poumons en modifiant l'attention sur la
membrane ils sont capables de produire
quasi tous les sons imaginables
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs j'en profite petit message
pour later rigolez pas en des perroquets
ont déjà fini en prison parce qu'ils
insultaient les passants c'est pas cool
parce qu'ils ne comprennent absolument
pas ce qu'ils disent ils ne parlent pas
vraiment même s'ils s'en donnent
l'impression par l'aîné de goût
définitivement pas une question
d'organes mais plutôt de cerveau les
animaux ont-ils le cerveau pour parler
si on regarde la taille des cerveaux
d'un perroquet d'un humain et d'un
éléphant on voit bien que c'est pas la
taille qui compte en réalité même un
très petit cerveau peut égaler certaines
capacités humaines
le cas le plus impressionnant est celui
d'alex un perroquet gris du gabon au
laboratoire il était capable de dire
combien il y avait un carré rouge et de
boule bleue et pouvait même faire des
additions jusqu'à 6 il connaissait la
signification de 1000 mots différents
étaient capables d'en utiliser lui-même
150 ils pouvaient différencier cinq
types de matières comme le liège la
laine ou le papier
enfin il maîtrisait plusieurs concepts
comme plus petits qu'eux ou au dessus
d'eux un jour placé face est un miroir
alex a demandé de quelle couleur il
était qu'on lui a dit gris il était le
premier animal à avoir jamais posé une
question et avoir appris la réponse tous
les soirs lorsque la scientifique qui
tel laboratoire
alex avait l'habitude de lui dire
bonsoir je vis dîner à demain je t'aime
c'est aussi ce qu'il a fait le dernier
soir avant sa mort c'est un exemple très
impressionnant mais beaucoup d'animaux
sont capables de ce type de prouesses
cognitives par des calculs mentaux
résoudre des puzzles ou des labyrinthes
les animaux ou bel et bien le cerveau
pour effectuer des raisonnements ce
n'est donc pas une bonne piste pour
expliquer leur absence de langage alors
peut-être que le cerveau humain pour une
capacité caché l'air de vernis que de
broca est ce là le secret du cerveau
humain qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc
eh bien ce sont les deux zones dans
votre cerveau qui vous permettent de
parler hier de vernet que vous permet de
comprendre les mots quand vous lisez ça
votre petite voix dans la tête le lit et
l'air de vernis que créer du sens l'ère
de broca elle vous permet de produire
les mots et donc de dire je m'abonne si
ces zones sont endommagés vous devenez
aphasiques réveil pendant pendant 30 ans
comment vous appelez-vous quel est votre
nom g mais récemment on a découvert qu'à
voir ces deux zones ne suffisait pas
déjà il faut avoir un contrôle très
précis et instinctif de nos cordes
vocales vous souvenez du singe qui parle
il ne produira jamais se sont par
lui-même
pourquoi parce qu'il n'a pas le contrôle
sur la centaine de muscles qui vous
permet de vous d'articuler les mots
c'est comme si je vous demandais de
bouger vos oreilles comme un chien vous
avez les muscles pour mais quasi aucun
contrôle dessus
l'autre découverte c'est un gène le
foxp2 qu'on qualifie de gènes de la
parole sa mutation peut entraîner une
incapacité génétique de parler
que ce soit pour articuler ou comprendre
les mots tous les animaux y possède mais
nous on a juste deux acides aminés
différence d'eux sur les 715 qui
composent la protéine codée par le gel
si nous parlons aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'un jour un homme préhistorique a vu
muté son foxp2 sans ça on serait encore
avec des ou ou des gestes deviner alors
ce qu'ont fait les chercheurs
qu'est-ce qui se passerait si on
implantait notre foxp2 dans le code adn
d'un animal
on l'a fait sur des souris elle se met
pas à part les humains mais elle
développe des capacités de communication
proprement exceptionnels avec leurs
ultras sont maintenant j'imagine que
vous voulez savoir ce que ça fait sur un
singe et bien les chercheurs considèrent
ça comme bio éthiquement immoral et
condamne toute expérience qui voudraient
donner aux singes des capacités
cognitives humaine cette musique
et oui bah oui ça c'est qu'en occident
parce qu'en chine l'expérience est en
cours et on n'est pas à l'abri qu'un
jour un singe par le mandarin quoi qu'on
en pense le gène foxp2 est déjà très
actif chez d'autres animaux par exemple
le diamant mandarin leur cui cui
ce sont des phrases construites et
structurer ces oiseaux parlent entre eux
ils ont même des accents et leur propre
langage qu'ils apprennent quand ils sont
tout petits
c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs que les
mésanges des villes et celles de
campagne ne chante pas pareil
on retrouve ce phénomène de langage a
pris chez d'autres animaux les chiens de
prairies sont capables de décrire
précisément une menace si l'animal est
petit ou aussi les carnivores s'ils
volent s'il à quatre pattes etc ou
encore plus impressionnant le langage
des dauphins qui semble capable de
produire des pales structure et de
s'écouter et de se donner des petits
noms vous l'aurez compris le titre de la
vidéo est complètement faux les animaux
parlent bien si juste nous qui ne savons
pas les comprendre
à moins que les scientifiques ont
peut-être une piste
pourra-t-on un jour traduire les animaux
vous avez peut-être déjà vu sur youtube
ces applications qui vous promettent de
traduire les aboiements et miaulements
de vos animaux de compagnie bon ça
marche pas mais est ce que c'est
possible
on l'a vu les animaux ont des cordes
vocales un cerveau développer la
capacité d'apprendre des concepts vont
potentiellement oui il parle un langage
qui est compréhensible
il existe déjà des dictionnaires de
singe les singes communique beaucoup par
leurs mains ou leurs expressions
faciales dégage attention tonnes -
manger viens jouer tout comme vous en
faites quand tu voyages à l'étranger et
que le vendeur n'est pas bilingue
tu parles de ce langage quasi
universelle qui est celui des signes un
indien du fin fond de l'amazonie
il comprend quand il pointe du doigt il
comprend quand il ya de la colère sur
ton visage
c'est un peu le langage par défaut ton
cerveau tout comme pour le sache et ça
d'autres animaux y pratiquer même les
plus petits prenons les abeilles elles
sont capables par une danse comme celle
ci de donner la direction la distance et
la quantité de pollen si dans l'exemple
le garde-manger plutôt éloigné de la
ruche elle utilise aussi les phéromones
et là encore l'humain est capable de
parler leur langage par exemple
l'acétate d'isoa mille l'arôme de
bananes en langage abeilles ça veut dire
attaque on sait dire par ici ne va pas
la haye au boulot même des trucs assez
précis comme les plus jeunes
n'allez pas butiner tout de suite on a
besoin de vous à la ruche donc oui
l'humanité à un dictionnaire des
phéromones pour parler aux abeilles pour
dicter leurs actions une compréhension
des animaux qui a déjà d utilité
pratique dans l'économie par exemple
avec les éléphants eux ils communiquent
avec des emprunts sont hors aubin on a
déjà notre petit dictionnaire des
infrasons d'éléphant et ça peut être
très utile pour les fermer par exemple
quand un éléphant s'approche trop près
de ton chant tu utilises l'infra son
attention aux lions pour qu'ils
s'enfuient imaginez maintenant pouvoir
faire la même chose avec vos chiens et
nos chats pouvoir parler leur langage un
rêve dans lequel a investi amazon avec
la start up the howling oit elle utilise
l'intelligence artificielle
analysant des milliers d'enregistrements
le chien un beau rêve qui pourrait
n'aboutir à rien les neuropsychologues
se demande encore si les modulations
dans les abonnements peuvent vraiment
être considéré comme un langage on sait
pas encore mais on progresse
la réponse à notre question départ est
donc plutôt positif
dans le futur il y aura des appareils
pour parler aux animaux
peut-être pas pour les chiens mais pour
les oiseaux ou les dauphins c'est déjà
en cours modifier le code génétique d'un
chimpanzé au point de le faire accéder
au langage est ce que c'est vraiment de
la science fiction y répondre est un
tabou scientifique
pourtant avec les ciseaux génétique tri
sparkasse neuf tout est possible et ce
n'est qu'une question de temps avant que
des scientifiques qui essaye vraiment en
attendant il faut humblement se dire que
le langage oral n'est pas le centre de
l'univers
il ya d'autres façons communiqué et on
doit
à inférioriser les autres formes
d'expression si un jour des
extraterrestres communiquer avec nous
uniquement grâce aux 1 façon on pourrait
ni les entendre ni leur répondre il nous
prendrait probablement pour une sous
espèce vivante
incapable de langage évolué l'idée
perturbante je sais et j'espère que
cette vidéo a pu vous aider à réfléchir
si c'est le cas dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire la vidéo a été
coécrite par julia qui nous a rejoint
récemment donc un big up à elle pour ses
recherches elle était fabuleuse pensez à
vous abonner à la chaîne pour nous
montrer votre soutien
c'est important pour nous c'est un
signal fort pour youtube aussi je
voulais vous remercier de monsieur de
plus en plus nombreux allaient les
habits
[Musique]